ob restaurants geschäfte ärzte friseure
supermärkte wer etwas sucht der googelt
google maps liefert uns scheinbar
passende antworten dazu die bewertungen
anderer nutzer
wir suchen nach einem reiseveranstalter
stoßen dabei auf einen anbieter der
extrem schlecht bewertet wird erwägt am
telefon stark alkoholisiert und das
schon am frühen nachmittag daher keine
buchung
doch können wir solchen bewertungen
vertrauen wir besuchen den
reiseveranstalter in der schwäbischen
alb jürgen armbruster bietet dort seit
vergangenem jahr wandertouren an es
läuft gut doch plötzlich tauchen auf
google maps massenhaft negative einträge
auf man merkte ihm an dass er ein bier
zu viel hatte er lallte und stotterte
die auskunft vor eine reine katastrophe
er erzählte mir bei einer tour dass es
eine frau betrogen und sich dabei viel
zu leise eingefangen hat er leiter am
telefon das kann bei einer höhlentour
tödlich enden
vorsicht das sind einfach dinge die die
belasten persönlich sehr schwer
also wo gibt es menschen die die nichts
besseres zu tun haben als andere an den
pranger zu stellen die nichts dafür
können und vor allem das schlimmste ist
dass da half auch die die existenz
wirklich aufs spiel gesetzt wird
wenn du vier wochen schreiben unbekannte
auf google maps 47 negative kommentare
und das in einem zeitraum in dem er
wetter und corona bedingt gar keine
touren anbietet als erstes habe ich mich
natürlich ein google gewandt mit der
bitte die bewertungen zu löschen weil
ich darauf hingewiesen habe dass die
bewertungen wirklich verleumderische art
und weise sind und auch den regularien
von google widersprechen
es kam dann eine andere antwort
eigentlich eine standard mal würde ich
sagen mit dem hinweis ja wir kümmern uns
darum aber passiert es dann über viele
wochen nichts zurück nach berlin
dort wollen wir uns mit einem
gastronomen treffen kriminelle bedrohen
ihn mit negativen bewertungen silvio
zeit betreibt seit vielen jahren das
gourmetrestaurant pankok plötzlich
erscheint eine negative rezension auf
google maps kurz darauf erhält er diese
e-mail
was wollen wir ganz einfach geld wie
viel
300 euro er soll das geld überweisen
damit die bewertungen wieder gelöscht
wird
sollten sie nicht auf unser angebot
eingehen werden die nächsten bewertungen
heftiger ist ja eindeutig ein
erpressungsversuch gewesen
wir haben erstmal kollegen angerufen ob
diese woche kriegt haben dann haben mich
kollegen angerufen
diese wird auch bekommen haben und da
sind wir natürlich gleich zur polizei
silvio zeit zahlt nicht die erpresser
machen ihre drohung wahr posten die
nächste negative bewertung einmal hier
gewesen direkt eine dicke
lebensmittelvergiftung zeit wendet sich
hilfesuchend an google bittet darum die
bewertungen zu löschen
google hat gar nicht reagiert wie es
reagiert sagte lösen wir nicht ist freie
meinungsäußerung und das bleibt bestehen
noch heute sind die einträge online
google lässt zu dass unternehmer
kriminellen hilflos ausgeliefert sind
kritisiert digital expertin anke
domscheit berg mit abmessung ist eine
straftat
das keine meinung und genauso ist
verleumdung keine meinung sondern eine
straftat wie bewerten wir dieses
verhalten
man sieht hier ein ganz klassisches
verhalten eines monopolisten der sich's
leisten kann rechtslagen bis hin zu
gerichtsurteilen einfach zu ignorieren
also das ist ein ganz klassisches david
gegen goliath wo ist also den google
riesen einfach gar nicht kratzt ob
irgendeiner sich darauf den fuß getreten
fühlt oder vielleicht in seiner existenz
gefährdet das interessiert die einfach
nicht wir fragen nach bei google der
konzern verwahrt sich gegen die vorwürfe
google investiere erheblich in die
bereitstellung zuverlässiger
informationen
zitat
wir überprüfen beiträge genauestens auf
betrügerische bewertungen
dafür setzen wir auf eine kombination
aus menschen und technologie wenn wir
feststellen dass menschen in die irre
geführt werden ergreifen wir umgehend
maßnahmen das wollen wir überprüfen
erkennt google tatsächlich gefälschte
bewertungen wir treffen den online
experten stefan tisch gemeinsam starten
wir ein experiment eröffnen im innenhof
des zdf zum schein ein café nennen ist
alice coffee shop nun registrieren wir
uns auf google maps und starten eine
kampagne mit negativbewertungen gegen
unser eigenes café wir legen
google-accounts an mit falschen
identitäten und schreiben miese ein
sterne rezensionen immer von ein und
demselben standort
google lässt 20 gefälschte negative
kommentare zu erst dann stoppt das
unternehmen die aktion zu lesen sind
solche einträge hygiene mangelhaft
geschirre dreckig serviert nie wieder
der blanke horror ekelhafter café die
bedienung ist unter aller sau was ziehst
du daraus für ein fazit ich bin erstaunt
und teilweise erschrocken dass es so
einfach ging
tappen ort bewertet an dem ich de facto
noch nie gewesen bin ja google überprüft
das nicht ob die person wirklich schon
mal hier gewesen ist und das hat folgen
je schlechter die bewertungen sind desto
geringer ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ein unternehmen auf google maps zu
finden ist
wir haben jetzt ja auch gesehen wenn wir
jetzt nach dem café suchen hier obwohl
wir quasi direkt vor dem café stehen
finden wir uns gar nicht aber andere
kaffee ist die bessere bewertung haben
also heißt wir sind eigentlich digitalen
sichtbar geworden zurück zu jürgen
armbruster
er hat inzwischen einen anwalt
kontaktiert und ist gegen google vor
gericht gezogen das hat per eilverfahren
entschieden google muss die negativen
bewertungen auf seinem profil löschen
google darüber per e mail zu informieren
sinnlos so die erfahrung des anwalts
auch diesen gerichtsbeschluss musste er
in irland der konzernzentrale für europa
zu stellen nur leider dauert diese
rechts förmliche zustellung recht lange
und so wurden dann noch mal mehrere
wochen vergeudet in denen man eigentlich
die bewertung längst hätte löschen
lassen können weil google natürlich wenn
sie die e-mails einfach zur kenntnis
nehmen würden dass das ganze hätten
bearbeiten können die bundesregierung
hat schon vor jahren versprochen die
position der verbraucher gegenüber den
mächtigen digital konzernen zu stärken
es geht um eine grundsatzentscheidung
für das digitale zeitalter
damit das internet nicht länger ein
rechtsfreier raum bleibt müssen wir
recht und gesetz auch endlich im netz
durchsetzen
doch erst jetzt hat der bundestag eine
eu-richtlinie in deutsches recht
umgesetzt
das gefälschte bewertungen verhindern
soll frage von sogenannten fake
bewertungen spielt ja immer eine große
rolle und das muss auch offen gelegt
werden durch die unternehmen ob und in
welcher form denn das tatsächlich
jährliche verbraucher bewertungen sind
google muss künftig darüber informieren
ob bewertungen auf ihre echtheit geprüft
werden
zu wenig um opfer krimineller
machenschaften wirklich zu schützen
kritisieren experten
wenn man täter nicht ermitteln kann weil
sie zum beispiel anonym sind und da wäre
es in diesen genannten fällen auch
extrem hilfreich wenn man über eine
anzeige bei der polizei die dann am ende
bestätigt ja es ist eine straftat
erreicht dass google die inhalte offline
nehmen muss das wäre wirklich
opferschutz und der geht auch wenn man
den täter nicht ermitteln kann
die betroffenen unternehmer fühlen sich
nach wie vor im stich gelassen ist ganz
furchtbar
dann macht die ganzen gastronomen
natürlich wütend wahrscheinlich nicht
nur gastronom auch den kleinen händen
eine ecke oder oder irgendwie das
problem ist eigentlich nicht wirklich
gelöst weil man ständig mit mit dem
gedanken lebt und umgeht so was kann
wieder passieren und es ist einfach
frustrierend zu zu erleben wie man in so
einer situation alleine dasteht
wir beenden unser experiment mit dem
café auf google maps sind wir immer noch
das mieseste café in ganz berlin